what's the last thing you google check
now okay
cow print um calcrip pants
oh my god what is actually so bad what
the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party
jesus this is unwaxed get in loser we're
going shopping with sophia and sistine
salome do we just become best friends
[Music]
yeah it's literally it's protein powder
it's protein powder i have to change it
i'm good
does anybody else have protein powder
that just makes them bloat horribly and
now i'm trying to figure out what to put
in my smoothie to get protein but i've
read somewhere hemp seeds okay great
hemp seeds are great i it's so funny you
said this because i actually googled
this yesterday and i said protein
powders that don't make you bloat
because i'm obsessed with a good
smoothie i'm like a [ __ ] for a good
smoothie but i feel like a whale after
eating it no and then people are like oh
you're eating it too fast i can't help
it no i used to make it all the time i'm
like what is making me so it's actually
at night that i start to get really
bloody it's like i'll have it in the
morning and then throughout the day it
just gets progressively worse and then
right before bed i feel horrible oh well
and i cut it out and now i have a magic
pill for that what
there's this pill that comes in a blue
bottle and it's called bye bye bloat
oh i've seen that [ __ ] is magic this
isn't even sponsored but
i get really bad bloating before bed too
and you take it before bed and you wake
up snatched it is it magnesium i don't
know what's in it i don't know i'm gonna
look at the ingredients i don't care i
don't care if there was a little bit of
what is this
crack
anyway
welcome back to another episode of the
unwax podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine um this episode we
kind of have no plan yeah
this is a rogue episode because sistine
and i normally when we do our episodes
we usually structure it a little bit
we'll have a topic we'll have some
subtopics to kind of remember but then
sometimes we go off book but now we
literally just wrote topics with nothing
underneath so maybe this will be the
most chaotic stupid episode but wow
those are my favorite though to listen
to we're doing this we're also going to
be drinking a little bit so maybe it's
let me tell you something let's get this
wait asmr
hello everybody and welcome back to the
podcast
that could have sounded like i want to
hear something actually very interesting
speaking of asmr sure
um there's this girl on tick tock that
does these really really good asmr i
think her name is ozly and i swear to
you
that girl is so good she calms me down
no she does these things to the camera
she picks your anxieties away and you
can feel it you get chills when you
watch her wait that's so funny it's the
sweetest eyes i've ever seen over
quarantine when i couldn't sleep if you
look up on youtube asmr to fall asleep
it is
so good it works yeah because asmr to
fall asleep and it's the most relaxing
sounds ever i never understood people
that would listen to the ocean with a
bunch of pelicans like ah like that
sounds horrible to know to sleep too
everyone has more torture
i forgot who'd said this to me once but
they said they prefer
putting on the sound of an airplane
to go to sleep and i i really could not
think of anything more torturous
than the sound of an airplane triggering
that makes me
i have to like take
80 grams of melatonin like last episode
that you did that literally gives me
like airplane pimples just thinking
about yeah
wait speaking of flying a lot
um
because you've been on a plane a lot
we're about to be on a plane again so
many planes it's like we are jet setters
baby we're all over the place everywhere
same time i mean i've gone to new york
twice palm beach once dc was crazy but
you know what i've realized mostly for a
boy which is worth the pimples
you know what
it's always worth it for love sophia it
really is it is
but you know what i realized that you
and i are the type of flyers that people
actually complain about why would we be
the ones
okay we are those [ __ ] that right
when the plane lands we stand up
not like we're going anywhere not like
it's gonna move the plane you know to
the terminal faster yeah i think we
annoy people a lot of people are like
what's the point of doing that yeah i'm
absolutely the first person on the plane
yeah and off the plane i did i can't it
actually stresses me out if i'm the one
of the middle people coming off of the
point yeah i am standing up immediately
i have to get my suitcase down i don't
just wait for
a second to grow
right when the seatbelt sign turns off
you're standing up yeah
we you can't go anywhere no you really
but i can't help it it's like nervous
anxiety to get me off no it really is
that but i think it's also because the
flights we take are not just two hours
they're six hours because we're going to
florida yes the time speaking of florida
very excited we're going back for easter
yeah and sophie and i were actually
talking about this the other day
and we were asking our mom we said
you know when you're young
easter is so much fun yeah the easter
egg hunt you get a little easter basket
why is it when you turn like 20
that just stops happening everything
stops happening when you turn older
everything what happened you realize
that holidays are not as i even
christmas i remember christmas being the
most amazing time of the year now
it's like i don't even turn on the radio
to hear santa talking to kids you know
it's like it seems so magical at the
time even easter i was like this is the
most amazing there's a bunny that comes
out and throws eggs everywhere and yes
fight each other for a chocolate egg
now
i miss no i miss the perspective of them
at 8 am that's like what you do on
easter
or is it now well not really
but the perspective that you had as a
kid for holidays was so charming yeah
you know like we were like oh santa
comes down the chimney brings you gifts
and there's an easter bunny that leaves
you little candy over here but if you
think about it as an adult
you got a fat man breaking into your
house that's santa you got a giant
probably like mutated bunny running
around your lawn wow that's kind of
scary
a six foot bunny isn't like that's a
little bit muted a little bit alarming
like if you actually think about all of
the holidays you celebrated as a kid
being like the tooth fairy
you've got a giant fly stealing your
teeth and whatever like that's crazy and
they're giving you money for it that's
what i'm saying like if you think about
it what came up with these that's a
little twisted you know okay so it's
funny because when um we go to eastern
this is the first time we're bringing
like our boyfriends and our cousins are
coming so it's really big and we're all
at least 23 and up
at least but we have to do something fun
yeah we have to we we should like why
don't we do something for easter well
you should say what i came up with the
other day
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah sistine said
to my mom jen
go buy some easter eggs we're having an
adult easter egg hunt think about it
instead of putting a tootsie roll in
there you put a little flask of fireball
perhaps a condom a condom
perhaps perhaps
a sex toy i don't know are you sexy
alcohol sex
we
are tainted let's do like things that we
want as an adult that we actually
okay money no put some liquid iv oh look
what ivs what are the things that we
love is adult chapsticks oh my god our
lips are always chapped advil pm advil
pm um um what would i want
i would like
um almond butter almond butter
butter so maybe some shavers i always
run out of those i always would have
shavers hair ties oh god hair ties bobby
pins it's like we're having an adult
this is a good idea things that we
actually need for our apartment i think
our boyfriends are gonna say either this
is really cool or what the hell is wrong
what the hell is wrong i think they're
gonna say this is really cool i hope so
i hope so i'm praying for it but i'm
really excited to spend that weekend
because we're gonna have a really a
really good time i think we have so many
things planned dinner wise and
social-wise and like i'm excited to show
people
that area that don't know it yes you
know i'm excited to sort of
let loose a little bit yeah we haven't
let loose well i think you have i think
you have okay yes i i have i just i've
been such a stickler when it comes to
drinking
and i used to be so fun yeah what
happened with you yeah that's i have to
say what did happen i don't know i don't
know am i the fun sister now
do not i by the way saw in the corner of
my iphone my girlfriend is nodding her
head no i am the fun sister now your
girlfriend's wearing velcro shoes i
wouldn't consider her
the prime example of judging over there
well she has a broken wrist and felt
close
okay so let's let's let's move on i
really want to talk about this i know it
may be a little bit
uh controversial and our opinions
probably mean squat but i want to talk
it's our podcast so you have to sit here
and listen to heartbeats
um the oscars
the oscars it was funny because
christine wrote that down i guess scene
i didn't even watch the oscars i didn't
either she goes we don't need to talk
about the oscars
no i want to talk about
the outfits and the slap scene around
the world i can't even tell you anything
about the outfits but i can tell you
about the slap that i saw i
could not believe that was actually real
yeah i thought it was scripted a lot of
people think it's the conspiracy theory
for some things
to get the show ratings up or
someone told me this conspiracy theory
about the alopecia and the hit
controversy to give like more right
reddit users have way too much time on
their hands to come up with that would
definitely be me
i used to love reddit that was my gym i
still love it but
that was crazy yeah and i'm wondering if
they're gonna take away his oscar or not
like do you academy do you think that he
should have it taken away i don't know i
don't know i don't know i think i think
maybe
i don't know if he was expecting to win
but i think when he won he probably was
like ooh
shouldn't have done that yeah you
shouldn't have done that like i
understand defending your significant
other and i understand uh standing up
for them but
there's a way you can do it yes without
hitting someone i mean that's all live
tv
live tv can you imagine if that happened
i understand he was laughing and then
all of a sudden it switched no but can
you imagine if that happened to you
you're presenting at the oscars you've
been preparing practicing your outfits
ready and then you just get smacked
you prepared
on national television did you see jim
carrey's interview after about it i did
and he was saying it kind of disgusted
him at the fact that people were
standing up clapping for that which i
totally agree with i mean like we
shouldn't be encouraging it i mean i
totally agree violence is not the answer
but then again i used to slap the [ __ ]
out of you so i'm a hypocrite for saying
that we used to have backyard fights it
wasn't my mom and dad said you want to
fight like dogs you go outside that's
actually true yeah they really held that
old school saying um
up because
whenever we would get in a screaming
fight they would put us outside in the
backyard and be like fight it out and i
would always win but then this is the
point we always say cestine can beat me
with her words and i'm psychologically
mentally breakdown slowly that's true
but i i slowly break her bones
oh my i don't know what's worse
okay but i was meant to say i do have to
say the best dressed in my opinion
was lily james
and versace yeah she looks beautiful i
don't know you know who i thought was
great was zendaya's outfit oh she looked
so good
kinda has been killing it kinda she has
not missed she's one who's her dresser
i don't know silas but one of them crazy
i could have
read this incorrectly but i think i
think i got it right she did her own
hair and makeup
no
i i actually wait i have heard that she
does her own makeup
if i did my own makeup i'd look like a
bald child yeah what the hell i for the
oscars yeah i couldn't do anything she
doesn't miss she looked so stunning yeah
and then there's always the vanity fair
after party where it's like all the
models and like everyone goes but
everyone always looks so much better for
that party than they do for the oscars i
don't yeah i don't know why either it's
always better dressed i don't understand
i always you know
when i used to be cool
i got invited i got invited one year to
the vanity fair oscar party and what
people don't know is
you see all those photos on that carpet
everyone looks so glam and all the stuff
but behind the scenes there's about a 30
minute line to get on the carpet so you
see all these celebrities posing looking
fabulous taking their moment but they
just waited 30 minutes in line to even
step on there which they look like
they're waiting to check out at target
they're oh it's like they're waiting at
like tsa like that's what it literally
looks like and they're like okay next
okay next shoe's off like what's your
name and that's what's and it's actually
true i'm sure people like kendall jenner
and them get to cut the line i sure as
hell got booted to the back i probably
waited an hour to get on the carpet i
think i think i got the last like three
photographers that were like oh we got
one more what's your name don't rock
don't wrap it up here
like the chapel like that's yeah okay i
think you just take the photo of you
talking mid-sentence yeah all right next
always yeah but those those parties are
so
crazy it's just very interesting to see
the dynamic behind the scenes yeah and
then you and a lot of people are not the
same that you oh man they let loose
and then also yeah it's celebrity
different they're just like us
well speaking of shows um so the new
season of bridgerton is out and i i
loved the first season this season's
actually not bad
we watched the first episode you were
not paying attention at all no i don't
even think did you even like the first
season
um i think i liked it because the
internet liked it and so i felt like i
had to like
sometimes it was a little boring
i feel like you feel like that with the
squid games too
yes i did i know everyone's gonna kill
me for that so the second season is out
but i have to say just a really quick
funny story and i'm gonna totally [ __ ]
on this show
there is this new reality show that's
out that's kind of a
a show like bridgerton where it's a
reality dating show in the school oh
it's they described it as like the
bachelorette meets bridgerton and so the
funniest part is is that a couple months
before they released the show oh god uh
the network came since the scene and i
talked about this idea and i for some
reason was kind of like you know this
doesn't sound like my thing but the
steam was gung-ho going wait i would
love to try this let me talk more she
went into like four different meetings
for this wait
she was about to be on a reality dating
show
feature like as like the girl in
bridgeton with always men so let me do
castle let me just back it up the only
way we're bringing this up is because
now sophia and i are actually watching
the the teasers are out and the
trailer's out
yeah and the show is out and we're
staring at each other like can you
imagine if i actually it's so bad it's
so crazy so bad i'm so i would pee my
pants if this was you so this is how
they pitched it to us we're sitting
there together and they said we're
looking for
a girl that is supposed to be like
the queen and then she has all of these
men trying to court her and they're
going to pretend like it's in bridgeton
era so you're going to be wearing those
classic gowns and the guys are going to
wear those penguins coats and they're
going to be ballroom dancing
archery and like you're going to pull up
on a horse and carriage and i'm like
this sounds
awesome and somebody's like this sounds
like the dumbest idea i was like this
sounds heinous i would be laughing so
hard if a man was like dude
it's like what the hell like they bow to
you and you have to learn these like
four steps so i go take my number well
it's following what's funny is like i
would sound like the one that would love
to do that yeah she was way more into it
so i said why not i didn't expect a
follow-up meeting and i didn't actually
even know what to expect at all so they
say go to universal you're gonna meet
with um universal and all of the
executives and the producers i thought
it was gonna be a room of three people
yeah i walk in and i'm trying to play
the part so i literally walked in in
this like
giant white poofy skirt that like
trailed on the floor i know exactly
which one you're wearing yeah and there
was like 30 executives in this room and
i was like holy [ __ ] and they're all
asking me questions like it was a panel
and i was like well i'm 23. i've never
been in love uh and i was just giving my
pitch and all this stuff and it's so
funny i just cannot believe it
i almost did that it would have been the
worst idea for you to ever do i don't
think you can bounce back from that no
like you know like i would love to go to
a bridge or teen themed party but to
have a reality dating show based around
that i don't know about that also i
probably wouldn't end up with the guy at
the end anyways it ended up being like
how this season oh no we always say the
only show that we'd ever do is love
island yeah the uk version only uk only
version
mora mora more more molly
um in other words news i'll cut that
back in other words
in other news um
our little sister scarlett
is in oklahoma right now yeah scarlett
is going to be on a movie or tv show
sorry she's acting she's doing her first
acting role right now as we speak as
we're recording this yes wow i should
text her good luck
the same
[Music]
[Laughter]
well well well she didn't say good luck
good morning to me well we're recording
today why didn't you say goodbye
anyway so she's she's in her trailer
right now she's getting ready she's
playing this like millennial barista
yeah oh that's perfect for her and i was
trying to tell her i'm like you know
what you should do to prepare sit in a
starbucks and just watch like just
observe and she's like no no you told
her no you told her so many things
you're like so scarlett sleep in like
make sure you know your lines prepare
for this
be ready and fresh to go on set this is
jack she's in college do you think she
listened to any of that nope nope nice
not
like kind of prepared with her i'm just
so i'm so excited for her but i'm so
nervous for her as well it's like my kid
i want her to do so well because she
wants to do this you know no she's gonna
do i think she's gonna do well i loved
when you were trying to pursue acting
that was my favorite
uh hobby of yours that you pursued it
was above piano above singing acting you
took the cake you were the worst at that
one the worst
i was really good at theater acting
horrible wait yeah go you can say it i
don't even know what you're gonna say
but i so
whenever you're
practicing or trying to do an audition
it's really important to film yourself
so you can watch it back and see
um what you did and what you want to
change and because it's one thing when
you're saying it you feel like it's good
but you your eyes and your body and your
body language there's so many different
mannerisms that you're not even noticing
so
you um
recorded yourself doing an audition
a practice one on your computer and you
wouldn't let me sit in the room with you
so i went onto your computer
and it's it's still there and i watched
it and it literally i think i pieced
myself
it was so bad
it was so bad we gotta watch it was it
was it dad do you have a line with me
the funniest part is his dad kept
telling me he's like no you're okay
one more time
is like you were trying to be like a
moody drunk and you're ha you have this
and you have this flask and dad's like
you know what we should actually put
alcohol in it because it's so bad i'm
drunk so sophia's drinking from this
flask and being like
it was so funny it's like it's so many
days and it actually got super busted i
got bugs because i kept taking because i
had to take like a couple swigs
throughout the year so think about i'm
like pouring straight tequila in that
yes and i'm taking like three shots the
scene i did probably like like what do
you take 20 takes like i was pretty i
don't even think i got to the end of my
life and i remember like towards the end
of you doing that because you kicked me
out i sort of peeked my head in at the
very end and it was like you were a full
drunk at that point you're like get out
get
[Laughter]
you know what let's bring this back
tomorrow morning
a little bit i just yeah thank god
that's just not my calling i'm i'm good
at this no you know what i don't you
know what movie that we both saw
recently that is so
good so we have good actresses
okay
hulu came out with a film called fresh
did you did you see it
okay it's about
um
sebastian stan yeah who
we stan him
he plays this uh cannibal
he plays cannibal and of course you're
like i don't want to see it but he gives
the exact same energy as joe from you
yeah where you're like this guy's a full
psychopath but i want him to stalk me
like i wanted sebastian yeah to eat my
arm okay that was close to being really
sexual
i said my arms no but yeah i completely
agree with that i was like rooting for
them to work out in the end i'm like
i was about to ruin something about it
but like
what he did to her and i still wanted
her to win like with him and now
why do we fantasize like horrible men
because we always like the guy that's
evil and dark to like have one love of
their life and we just want that to work
for some reason like this is toxic it's
so toxic but it was his finest
same thing because he's hot i guarantee
if he was an ugly
cannibal we'd be like yeah kill him but
he's hot we're like that's how well
that's how we felt about joe from you
were like if this man that i'm dating
isn't willing to murder someone
for me is that even love yeah like how
much love are you knocking he's
sacrificing like my right leg because he
loves me that much like that's love
that's love like thank you if he's not
stalking my enemies and making sure they
stay away from me like that's love no
it's like why are we together so do you
remember we made oh my god i miss we
should do this again remember we did
powerpoint night
i love powerpoint and i made a
powerpoint what was it called it was
like it was um men that are psychos in
film but i would low-key date and like
one of them was like pennywise
version of the title if we're gonna be
honest here oh yeah that was the pc yeah
one of them was like pennywise from it i
know what you're saying
under the clown mask he's super cute
yeah and by the way he likes kids and
balloons like why is that bad
why is that bad
he likes face paint he likes face paint
i love makeup i mean like why not he's
probably good at it
you know what i mean the other one was
like jason mamoa from game of thrones
like yeah he eats human heart
you said tom he could have my heart you
said um what was his name why am i
forgetting killing murphy from killikin
murphy well that's like obvious peaky
blinders
yeah he's but he's a good guy he's not
an evil uh
yeah he's gangster he kills people
that's true he has razor blades in his
hat
but i also always run out of razor
blades so like i need to shave my legs
like do you see how there's always a
silver lining yeah in these men mine was
pretty aggressive mine was people i
would love to just like pin down and
punch if i had the opportunity yeah i
feel like you were going through a
moment like yeah i was oh my god i put
people that i know personally actually
most of them were like one person i
wanted to know it's supposed to be like
cartoon characters but then i was like
oh plot twist let me add like people i
know as a joke no a few celebrities you
kind of nailed though yeah oh we're
going to stage coach this year yeehaw
so excited so excited and sophia
actually made a pact do you remember
what that pact was it was
to just go with each other
or no or go with the boyfriend if we had
one
we said the next time we go to this
festival we better both be having
full-on relationships and we bring our
boyfriends
and look at that manifested it probably
probably i'm so excited about it i love
it there's nothing i love more than a
cowboy boot and a mini skirt and i just
wish that we could wear that more
uh casually in public without being
looked at funny like why is that bad oh
i don't think it's that bad well well
i mean we're in l.a so you can kind of
wear whatever you want no but like when
you see a girl at like a fun restaurant
in a cowboy boot you're like
that's corky and bold like yeah like
that's so sick
yeah that's true that's true well now we
get to do it that weekend and we're
already i'm planning my outfit out i
need to actually be good at this stuff
i'm always the person that does things
last minute and i always look the photos
going why didn't i just put one
hour you actually do everything last
minute meanwhile
me
i actually made a three-page powerpoint
of my outfits that's a little excessive
what's with you in power points right
now i have a lot of time i love
powerpoint i have a lot of time on my
hands but i was like you know what
it's so smart i've already
organized exactly what my look's gonna
look like i have the links for
everything i'm ready to go right no
stress on my end you're going to be
hauling ass last minute freaking no and
i want to look good and my boyfriend's
going to be there so i'm going to like
also look cuter why'd you whisper when
you said that
stop
don't come down
actually speaking of boyfriends um he
asked me to
marry you
i mean guys did you notice no um
he asked me to it's just the only way my
fingers are kind of swollen it's the
only one that really fits if you can see
that when it's on my phone why are your
fingers swollen i don't know
it's all that protein powder it's
bloating us all that sushi i had last
night but
he asked me to make a playlist of music
i really like oh [ __ ] i got you i know
you do do not no but do not stressful
because half of me is thinking okay i
want to put the music i like but my
taste of music is so you listen to like
lord circa 2000 that sounds true yes
it's 1975 is like primarily what i like
this is what i do my love language is
making a playlist for a guy that i like
i've got this
i got this by the way you are not making
a playlist for my boyfriend you don't
have to tell him it's from me i know but
the whole purpose is that it's from me
and you want to say i like music is a
little whack it's not wow you're always
like a year late to the truth you choose
artists just because they have maybe
like two listens on spotify you're like
i found them before they got famous
but they're good
i have good artists sophia i do like
disclosure would come out with a song
and then two years later like did you
hear this new song when a fire started
that is such a cool that's so pretty i
showed you oceanized by billy eilish
before she was billy eilish before and
this was so long ago when she saw the
super white hair so yeah i can start
trends but i half of me is thinking okay
i want to add i actually did put some
good older songs that we like because he
also has i think a little bit the same
taste as i do like you are very specific
with your genres and also everything is
emotionally charged with every place
that you have and it's kind of i like
music that makes me feel sadder yeah
when i'm sad she has yeah she has like
playlists to make her cry more which is
interesting so
i just want to figure out if i should
put stuff on there that is that i think
he would like more if i just keep the
things that i like and i just feel like
it's a it's a big deal i feel like if
you give someone a playlist it's
basically selling your soul i it's not
selling my soul it's like giving a part
of my soul
okay
little deep
but
i do think curating a playlist for your
partner is
so romantic and it's such a cute little
thing that you do in the beginning of
like almost every relationship yeah and
then you have to title it something
really cute it has to be an inside
joke or
something that only you two would
understand i have one
great yeah
but make me a collaborator i gotta no i
gotta help i'm not giving you a playlist
that says like also helped with this
nobody's gonna know it says collaborated
with how are they gonna know huh who's
gonna know how they gonna know how how's
your um apartment coming together
because i feel like we're pretty much
settled in no i'm not at all yeah i was
settled in but now my
i'm one of those people if my
apartment's messy i actually can't think
straight yeah and so now i feel super
frazzled in my apartment because there
are boxes everywhere again i keep
ordering stuff i realize i'm like i
actually haven't hung my mirror any
photos i need outdoor furniture i
switched bodies yeah i am so organized
yeah you're so done i'm handy well
you've been in town i have not been in
town for like at least a solid full
weekend in a while i was gone for a week
yeah but you had time for a week by
yourself to like organize this stuff you
know what i did the other day
i replaced my shower head
by myself is that
i don't need no man is there a small
leak yeah
that's all american woman here extra
drizzle i mean i did that um i feel like
there are certain things now that i'm
realizing at 23 i'm like whoa this is
adult status yeah like keeping a plant
alive
that's mature you're you're willingly
wanting to buy a live plant i already
did and i'm watering it
once a week which is
what they require
and i'm like this is so exciting or
writing in a calendar i'm like when you
physically write it yeah i write it in
my calendar this is great but i realize
how much i don't carry my calendar so
when people ask for my plans i have no
idea who's asking for your plans don't
you you're not like sophie you are not
like let me check my calendar and pull
it out of your purse yeah if i have to
like say yes to a dinner or an
appointment no
though i'm okay i am an adult i'm
allowed to have like plans and stuff but
no i have to like type it into my phone
as well because i realize how dependent
i am on my phone and it's just
frustrating another adulting thing that
i've done recently i don't even
recognize myself for this one um
i went into a bookstore
on accident
no
i was looking for the bathroom uh on
purpose because i was like you know what
like i'm gonna start reading i need to
lower my screen time you're gonna start
reading so i go in i picked out a book
based off of what i did no you know what
i'm about to compliment you you [ __ ]
why don't you stop you just [ __ ] on me a
second ago listen i was in the bookstore
i was going through the aisles thinking
i had no idea what i even want yeah
right
what did i do i go on instagram i look
up favorite favorite book club
and i go on your instagram and i find a
wreck and i bought it which one you
should talk to someone
oh yeah maybe you should talk to someone
yes there was a tissue box on the cover
so i was like this seems like you know
who actually gave me that book
gabby did yeah you're a fraud i'm not a
fraud
i read it for my book club because she
recommended it well thanks gabby i got
it from you i know i know i didn't do
anything it was all gabby crazy i know
but thanks for checking out favorite
book club if you guys want to book her
dishes remember when you made me reader
of the month yeah i stopped doing that
because a lot of people were like i
don't want my public profile out there i
go okay fine i wanted to do something
cute for the community and also i've
been lacking on it really bad why
because well one this month i really
wanted to read one book and it just i
don't have time to read four other books
and
create a lot of content for it and so i
just just
run back that sentence you just said i
don't have time to read four books
i barely can get through like 20 pages i
know well
the whole point of my the club is i read
three books a month whoops and this
month i'm reading a book that's 800
pages and i yeah which i'm almost done
with and i got gabby hooked on to the
author thank god sarah j maas if you
want a really good fantasy author she's
probably my favorite and the best um and
i just have to focus on that because she
takes up all my life
oh my god 800 pages i know next month i
have books coming back but it's so long
but it's so good if you can find a book
that is really good honestly 800 pages
is nothing you don't even realize to get
back into it's so hard for me to find
something i get hooked on because i'll
read a book the last 30 pages i'll just
stop i first know why i would say and i
always say this to people if they're
trying to find a good book obviously ask
your friends recommendations at first
i used to say check book talk that's
like go on tick tock but but a lot of
these tick tock book recommendations are
really cheesy sponsored too they're
sponsored or they're just over hyped and
they're really not that good so i just i
don't know you just have to find your
niche you liked uh erotica
and erotica and suspense wait i never
finished that book that you gave me the
dare
yeah you did you ever no i didn't i
never finished i said i know you didn't
so okay i remember a few episodes back i
said i was gonna bring it in and read
like a few chapters or a few lines out
of a chapter yeah should i still do it
that'd be funny i think i'm still on the
clown
sophia the book is four chapters yeah
halfway through
i know i feel like since i've gone to
boyfriend i've said boyfriend 400 times
on this one episode it's almost like i'm
trying to brag like my boyfriend at
night but you should it's something
you've waited for for such a long time
yeah it's exciting i know he's the best
but um so he's coming into town next
weekend and
his family's from here so i i'm meeting
the family for the first time dude
schvitzing yeah that i'm already like
right now
uh yeah so nerve-racking
i do well with adults and i feel like
i'm pretty good in these situations but
it's so
so nerve-wracking especially since um he
only has um his it's his mom dad and
sister and it's like you know
when a guy has a sister you want to make
sure the sister likes you a lot too oh
that's cute and the mom especially of
course oh obviously the dab the dad's
it's a different situation
i feel like as a female it's always easy
to win over the doubt but like trying to
win over other women they just say golf
and they're like hard yeah golf cigar
bourbon cool they're like okay cool
you're awesome and then with the mom and
sister you have to make sure like okay
because they can read girls they can
they can stick out a girl that's fake i
know i'm not fake but i just you know
it's really intimidating and i always
feel like i have to refresh my my brain
before i go into these situations
thinking okay what do i need to do what
do i need to wear what do i need to say
ah sofia i think the hardest thing even
when you're meeting anyone not even if
it's just the boyfriend's family if
you're meeting anyone we have a bad
habit of
altering our personality and our energy
levels and sort of becoming someone that
we assume that they would like but
you're so likable
in itself you don't need to change your
personality you don't need to do extra
do more because sometimes also if you're
true eager beaver they're gonna be like
okay she's trying way too hard she's a
little annoying annoying like just be
yourself i know i always i'm trying to
be the mostest and i feel like if you
establish that you're already a loud
person right off the bat you're already
gonna
now they're gonna think okay if she's
not loud she's in a bad mood or she's
just yeah [ __ ] this one up you're done
they're gonna tell you chatty sophia i
know they're gonna call me like that's
what we called you in middle school
remember chatty sophia you just like one
stop talking oh yeah i was that kid that
always when i was dead silent in
situations had to talk yeah and feel the
air
i still do that i really do still do
that i like i try to not i intentionally
have to tell myself to stop talking
oh my god i know and so i'm hoping i do
that i just i know i need to make sure i
wear something that is
fashionable but very sophisticated has
to be
mature but not i remember what i wore
what did you wear i looked like an
equestrian writer oh i actually wear
what you wore i wore like uh a blazer
and i buttoned it with like a
silk blouse underneath i looked very
mature it looked like you were going to
a
business meeting that's what you want
this isn't a business meeting this is
you're like here is you're like uh hello
sharks i'm asking for
your son's time for 20 and i want your
affection and i want your love and
approval
um here's what i have what do you do
when let's just say i'm not saying this
is gonna happen with me but and i know
it's not with you but
what do you do when you're dating
someone and the family is horrible but
it's not your fault
how do you handle that you like
everything else you do in life you just
gotta figure it out there's no like
right answer and every situation is
different but it sort of just depends on
how your partner handles it and yeah
making sure that they
understand and see where you're coming
from
because you can't just say oh your
family's making me uncomfortable and
they wouldn't understand yeah um i don't
know that's a tough one i feel like i
haven't exactly dealt with that myself i
know i never either i i don't i don't
think don't think the worst no i i think
it's gonna go well
i just i know you're nervous because you
just want everyone to like you well it's
also i
uh because he doesn't live here it's one
of those situations where it's once in a
blue moon i'll really get to talk to
them so it's like i got one shot well
maybe i can like sneak in the night
before and hypnotize them or something i
have an idea why don't you just come
with me
you know i would that would be fun i'd
be like you know my sister actually
really wanted to join this and i'll
hypnotize them
like sophia
have one of those like light fingers oh
my god yeah no it'll be good i i think
it's good
he was able to do it in a tuxedo and it
would ball in the ball gown gala
great he'll if i if he can do that i
think i can do it'll be so good yeah uh
sophie and i are sipping our little
bubbly over here we thought we're gonna
play a little drinking sister game that
our producers have written up for us
that we don't know the questions so
basically what we're gonna do is we
don't know what the questions are we
just got them sent we're gonna read them
and we're both gonna answer them
so if we sip we're not answering it if
we spell we're going to answer it so if
we don't want to answer the question
you're going to hear some asmr of us
slurping yeah
all right do you want me to start go for
it question one oh boy
have you ever had sex when the family
has been home
i mean like
i hate it because i know mom listens to
this i want to sip or spill sweetie
she's sipping all right uh i'm really
that's like very
what's one thing you lied to your mom or
dad about recently oh my god so many
things i definitely feel i just need to
pick one i know
i feel like
i feel like i tell
a lot i feel like i'm a good lie teller
but in
the the mindset that i just don't want
to hurt someone like i never just
see i'm more for the benefit of myself
oh nice nice nice okay let me think
something i lied about recently um
maybe
oh i was facetiming one of them and i
lied that
i had to get ready for something else
just to get off the phone
does that mean yeah of course no it's
not me but i've done that i i one time
told my mom that um like she wanted me
to go to a lunch with her and her friend
i remember i was like oh sorry i have to
meet coffee with my friend from
something there was no friend no i just
went to coffee by myself just i didn't
have to go sorry mom sorry um who is
your favorite sister
it's hard cause it changes but i love
both of them so much like right now you
because you're in front of me yeah
that's how i feel you're in front of me
it's my favorite but then i spent a week
with scarlett in palm beach and i would
say scarlet because she was in front of
me i don't know if i've i don't scarlet
have i ever been skrull's favorite all
the times when you guys are fighting
well yeah that's the thing it depends on
who's in a better mood with which this
yeah yeah currently i'd say you yeah oh
thanks okay so we're good okay thank god
i'm like all right have you ever lied
and told me i looked good even though i
didn't
oh no
you probably have for me but i know i
haven't for you actually no i i'm very
honest we are very honest with each
other so i'll tell you if it like it
doesn't work but you'll always tell me
if it doesn't work either most of the
time it's me telling sophia your outfit
doesn't work yeah yeah it's i really
have to do that for sustain yes most of
the time it's me always yeah okay maybe
i'll just say that she looks pale but
like i won't
yeah you know what you know what you
always tell me no more blush yeah i do
i'm like god very well and i tell you
start over yeah she's like that shirt
those pants that doesn't work together
nothing works
cosmetic surgery go um
what's one thing you hate about me
oh i can answer this i don't want to
sift um
one thing i hate about you i don't hate
anything about you but if i wish you
could change something about yourself
is
i wish you didn't overthink so much
especially things that came to you
because you have a really good gut
instinct and you always seem to question
it
instead of listening to it so i think
that like if you just went with your
first initial reaction which is always
the right one you would save so much
time of like overthinking and
conversations and worrying and stressing
yourself out for nothing yeah
um what do i hate about you
you're like your pants your face your
pants your personality
and your
um
i would say
that
i don't like
how secretly hard you are on yourself
no like you're so hard on yourself and
it pisses me off like you like analyze
every single part of your like being and
well i don't understand
you're perfect
oh thank you also i hate when you like
mentally play mind games on me and you
make fun of me to like get really
insecure
i hate when you answer the phone pissed
like i'm trying to have a fun time why
are you pissed
i hate when you wear those stars on your
face
like they're badges of honor they're
pimple patches exactly give me a break
i hate
that you put almond butter on everything
what's wrong with your arteries are
gonna get clogged
i was gonna say one i can't say it i'll
just sip that
okay what is the next time is it my turn
yeah what's the last thing you google
check now okay
okay
history
cow print um cow print pants
oh my god why it's actually so bad i
can't
i was about to buy cow cow print pants
for stagecoach i would love like a cow
what did you put do why didn't you look
at them oh my god look at i can't even
read it because people are going to
think i'm lying read read the top one
the very top one
it's a youtube search
why would you look that up
tub with international model
what is this
what
okay okay my last google search was hot
tub with international models yeah mine
are not fun
and let me explain mine's let me explain
let me explain it's a david dobrik video
and it says it looks bad but that was
the title yeah it looks like uh like a
pornhub title hot tub international
model
all right that was a good one actually
oh that was so fast okay next one says
what's the most embarrassing thing you
said during sex
stop
um
i can't admit i can't say it
because it's really let's see
what's something you haven't told your
boyfriend yet
oh
i secretly hate
that
he kind of leaves a mess
every time he leaves my apartment and i
work so hard to keep it clean
also
um
there's like little black hairs like all
over my couch it pisses you off yeah
because it's a white couch so
and it won't come off like i'm trying to
vacuum them
sure i keep flipping the cushions but
it's on the other side so
oh i mean that it's i have a really hard
time sleeping in the same bed with him
and we're like i like i can't
not not because i would say the same not
because it's him or anything but it
takes me so long to fall asleep and i
don't want to tell him that i know it's
a terrible thing yeah because he's going
to take it personally and then he's
going to think it's him
all right
um what's your biggest turn on i have so
many
i can't pick one
but when they
are
like ignoring me
and then i get like god yeah you know
sophia i'm kidding my biggest turn-on is
that i'm like properly courted like
old-school way if i get picked up and
the door's open for me and then we go to
a restaurant and they're like let's get
a bottle of wine for the table and then
they say what would you like and then
they order for me i'm like oh my god
like
i love oh oh i know one it's such a
random one because i wanted to change up
i actually completely agree with you on
that because it's just like oh they're
taking charge but for some reason when
he's on a call
for a business meeting or for his
company and he's answering some
questions or he's talking about numbers
and whatever it is and stats for some
reasons
i just i think that's so hot i'll do
another one i don't know i'll do another
and he doesn't believe me i'm like i
love you on the phone and i was like why
like
extra points if they have like air pods
in or something airpods and they're
using their hands while they're like
discussing numbers
do you know what i mean like pacing
around the room yeah like they're very
in it i like when a guy is backing out
of a parking spot and they put their
hand over your seat and look back and
like
oh god oh i love that i know i love that
i love i know one a really really good
cologne a good clown a really good one
like a really uh one that they use all
the time but every time they go out and
it's like a nice event you no it's going
to be i like
when they have very veiny hands
it's perfect for taking blood
mosquitoes love you mosquitoes love you
i love you i also really like how many
things when they dress super well
like if you look like a calvin klein ad
at night and then
a ralph lauren ad during the day
love that
love that
i also oh no no no i've i've just you
know chill i think one that i recently
kind of noticed is that i love when
when you come when you dress really well
for something and they just like look at
you and they give you these eyes like
like i don't know you look beautiful or
something they don't have to say
anything there's like smiling at you
another big turn-on is when you're in
public and maybe around his friends your
friends or even no one that you know
and like they sort of just do something
like grab your hand or like touch your
back to be like you're mine yeah like
yeah because we don't need the whole pda
thing like i don't need you to show that
like i'm with you yeah 50 of the time
but when they sort of reassure you
you're like oh biggest turn on loyalty
humor confidence ghosting kindness and
ignoring me but then also coming back at
the end of the day ignoring me
no that was actually kind of fun that
was a lot of fun did we miss anything i
don't think so
this is a very chaotic episode yeah
sophia i'd like to know something
what sistine did you delete all of your
dating profiles yes i haven't had it for
years oh that's good
sistine yes
do you still stalk the exes
so thirsty
perched
sophia yeah do you still think about
what life would look like if you were
with
your exes
oh
my god
no
actually no liar no i don't
okay
um sophia that got me really nervous but
now
also if i guarantee if i sipped in
general uh i haven't had a question for
you
asked
what are you embarrassed that you are
wearing abercrombie
oh my god and i spilled on myself uh
are you i'm embarrassed i spilled on
myself
i'm just kidding i bought from there
last week
you're the you're evil oh
no i'm proud to be wearing abercrombie
because they're making an epic comeback
yeah they are re rebranding they said
[ __ ] the moose
we're going cool
sistine what how are you really doing
how are you really feeling today
my
emotional state
is hanging on
by the thread
of a piece of dental frost
and that's all the time we have
i'm about to break
we love it and cheers to that cheers to
hanging on to it on a thread thank you
guys so much sophia's hammered we need
to go we need to go okay thank you guys
so much we had um i don't even know what
this episode was it was a fun sister
ketchup this is a good kiss yeah
sophia
i got a driver home i'm the designated
driver we're going to pull trig babe do
not worry thank you guys so much for
watching this week's episode it's so
sloppy thank you so much for watching
stop you're not going to talk anymore
we'll see you next tuesday
[Music]
you